hello and welcome to the 33rd ever
episode of the iced coffee hour i'm
elena and as of today
the podcast has made thirty thousand
dollars and eighty thirty thousand
eighty six dollars great we're going to
keep it we're gonna go
right great job thank you so much thank
you
all the way from new york yeah this is
true this is for this
just just like this yeah we feel honored
thank you thank you so much
yeah especially after my video on you i
know
you know you are nicer than i expected
really oh yes
now to bring everyone up to speed on on
what's happened here some background
uh you were on a cnbc video correct
called what was it
unlocked unlocked and this is one of the
first unlocks that they have done yeah
was it the first the first the start of
a great team yeah so you were in an
episode
by cnbc which of course i watched them
all and then of course
i react to them and you were one of the
episodes i reacted to
correct and people were giving you a
really tough time in the comments about
where you live and how much you spend in
rent
and funny thing i've actually seen your
channel before i don't know how i
i see basically every youtube channel
out there
i kind of feel like right you get to
know everybody yeah so i saw
your channel before recognized you from
that watched your episode
had some critiques overall some good
things to say
but uh let's go back before we do the
confronting series
um tell us a little bit about yourself
you do youtube i do
yes i'm a youtuber as well content
creator i
would say i primarily create content on
lifestyle so it was primarily travel for
a while and obviously
you know things have changed and that
was kind of like the trajectory was
supposed to go on into 2019
and so yeah i kind of had to reevaluate
so this past year we're making a lot of
content
specifically on new york city a lot of
apartment content
been delving into the world of finance
as well which has been fun
and then just other like fashion
sustainable fashion uh
beauty a little bit of everything yeah
and how long have you been making videos
on youtube
it's been a minute so i technically
started my channel in 20
what is it now i guess 2015. but it was
like 2017 was when i really
like committed to it and started making
yeah a lot more did you go to college or
when you
did yeah yeah i went to school in san
diego and yeah graduating in 2018 and
then we've got new york
and why youtube uh yeah good question i
guess
for me my story would be that i i
watched youtube
a lot i loved youtube in high school
like that like 2013
2014 youtube personality i was always a
fan
and growing up as like a teenager
preteen i love making videos so i was
already editing a lot
i was already used to like you know
holding the camera editing the whole
process
and then eventually i just kind of
decided to stick to it as like a
creative outlet
and yeah kept it up and how long do you
think that you were on youtube until
you considered it to be like
self-sustaining and yeah sufficient
a while yeah i never had a viral video
never
just like never just fully picked up i
remember when my channel was smaller at
about like 50 000 i had a youtuber
friend who was further along
and she told me that when you hit 100k
is when you can like pretty much go full
time and so it was like
the day after i graduated college i hit
100 000 subscribers wow i was like all
right
gotta gotta go for it and so yeah i'd
say you're wrong again was the youtuber
friend shelby
can we say no don't we tell you yeah it
doesn't matter allegra shot which i
don't know if you know who that is
yeah it was like a glossier event dabble
in that
beauty world of youtube as well so
that's good advice what's glossier
it is a uh basically like a beauty
skincare brand
yeah cool yeah all right and how much
money were you making back then a
hundred thousand like 50
100 are you okay
as they say so i would say that first
okay i would say like in 2018 so my
first year
full time so i graduated may 2018 i
spent the summer traveling and then i
moved to new york
in september and so by the end of 2018 i
think i made 50 000.
so i wasn't making big bucks 50k and
that was at 100 thousand subscribers
and my channel did grow quite a bit that
year so i probably i graduated in may
with probably
a hundred thousand and then i would say
i hit like 250 000 by the end of the
year so there was a big growth spurt
that was the one time i had like a big
growth spurt i'd say no the 50 000 is
that mostly adsense or was it
sponsorships or what mostly sponsorships
i've never made a lot of adsense money
really why is your cpm just lower it's
so low
it's so low it's insane in comparison
how low
like four or five dollars wow cpm or rpm
rpm all the time i can show you guys
i can pull up numbers i'm not going to
top my head but you want to pull it up
let's see let's see
let's see this is our finance channel
we're going to die we're going to dive
into this
let's also this is obligatory
but are you comfortable screenshotting
so i can have a visual
screenshot okay all right cool all right
let's pull the video
as an example see look
yeah no way okay so so it's what is this
this is a college room tour how to style
a small room
uh in the last well okay 1100 views two
five dollars and twenty one
but that's also the amount of money
you've made in the last 28 days yeah
let's see if i go
all the time yeah two thousand dollars
and how many views did it get eight
hundred thousand yeah so we would be
eight hundred thousand what is what is
that like eleven twelve thirteen
thousand
dollars yeah that's got to be tough
i think you're underpaid i mean you got
to think absolutely sponsorship sponsors
do well that's the thing is like i have
to do a lot more sponsorships
than some youtubers and sometimes people
know they're like why are you doing so
many sponsorships in comparison to um
other youtubers but like this year on
adsense i made like thirty four thousand
dollars for the year
and i had like 12 million views or
something like that so if you're in the
lifestyles here there's not a lot of
money in adsense
that's really livable but you also can
market you would market your instagram
account oh yeah i mark it i market that
for sure yes
why is business going down on instagram
no but i think there's a lot more
instagram deals in the beauty fashion
so there's definitely sponsorship money
there but there's not ads
okay let me ask you this uh are you
putting mid-roll ads in your videos
i usually do if it's a 12-minute video
i'll usually do like the
click the before and after and i'll
usually do two so i'll do one like the
three-minute mark when i like the
nine-minute mark
okay yeah all right well that's good
that's weird yeah that's fair okay yeah
wow okay i expected much more especially
you walk in with a new iphone
living in new york no kidding i expected
way more ad revenue than that
not quite sponsorships
yeah got it okay so you living in new
york now
that was what the episode was about you
had two roommates right so the total
rent
was 5400 a month correct split that
between
three people total so your portion is
not that bad you lived in a nice place
yeah not bad at all good decorating how
did you thank you cnbc reach out to you
from that or you reached to them yeah
they reached out to me and i think they
found me through youtube
because i've done quite a few apartment
tour decor
videos and so i think they just found me
through that okay
what was it like reading some of those
comments on that video saying that new
york is so expensive that you were
wasting money
living there they were telling us they
were telling you you're making a big
mistake
i know well i i was expecting it because
i watch so refinery29 has a similar
series it's an apartment tour
and if you look at the comments it's
exactly the same so i knew i was getting
myself into like i knew people would not
be
kind or even understanding but like i'm
obsessed with street easy which for
those who are unfamiliar it's like
the new york apartment hunting app
essentially i'm obsessed it's literally
part of my morning routine i check it
every day for months so i'm very aware
of what's a good deal or not i'd say
like four specifically what i'm looking
for in my budget
amount of rooms so i feel like what i've
got was a good deal but people are
always going to be like why are you
spending that much you could be living
in
pennsylvania and like get you know so
much more like even living in different
parts of the city
because i was living in a pretty like
prime neighborhood you could say
um so yeah i do remember you saying that
it's wise for you to live in new york
and especially in that area because
there's so many content opportunities
totally
and that does make sense when you put it
like that because then it's just like a
business
expense yeah how you're living there
exactly yeah that was my
uh i came to the defense yeah and i said
it makes sense for what you're spending
it's not that bad
no yeah exactly i figured you'd
understand but i did tell you
that you shouldn't be living there
full-time and that ideally you got to be
traveling more i think if you did van
life i think that was my
that was my recommendation i think i'd
say that to everybody like if
if they just did van life they would do
so well so well on youtube
that's what's crazy are you thinking
about doing it i didn't do it actually
you did
no so you kind of hit it on the nose oh
did i miss these i missed i missed it
i doubt i usually researched this but
okay last summer so
i lived in a van for a bit and i loved
it how was that i'd love to do it again
oh my gosh it was great was that by
yourself or did you do that me and my
boyfriend we went on a long trip
yeah rented a van and it was great wow
and normally we would be
traveling too as well that was my kind
of focus on my channel
but where did you go um i went up the
coast
so up through so i'm yeah again
originally from orange county so i'm
staying with my parents at the time
and went up through oc la up through big
sur san francisco
mendocino and all the way to the lost
coast of california how long did you go
for
uh probably like a week and a half so it
was a dabble it wasn't like i would
never claim to be a van lifer
that's not graham wants to do it forever
i know you got to do it for like a year
yeah
i guess i i've done that drive before up
to san francisco
and it's a it's a nice drive you could
do that in a day
so but yeah the northern part of
california is a lot
larger than i expected i guess you know
on the outskirts
it keeps going and there's lots of
little nooks and crannies to explore but
no i would
by no means call myself what you need to
do is do it from
la to new york instead of
instead of taking a flight back get a
van
i'm into it four or five grand deck it
out do something crazy in it and then
travel and then
do podcasts okay on the way out there
that's that's what i would do
i honestly thought about that it would
be great travel content too i would do
that that's smart a podcast would be
cool and you just talk about the
different places yeah
that's what i've thought i've been
telling jack i mean i think at some
point i really want to do the whole van
line
you can't recruit me to like sleep in
the back
well you travel with macy and i'm just
like you're there okay
just constantly yeah i'm literally a
hundred percent
just 24 7 at 30. so i thought this i
thought we could get like a giant
rv you got like not not quite a van but
like an
rv with a trailer in the back and
jack would be in the trailer
yeah i love it oh my god so that way
jacket on his own spot but what we would
do is just
go from like every state like all 50
states visit them maybe to do like a bit
of a travel
not not a vlog but like a little travel
segment or something
and then do podcasts like at every state
every location
that way jackson is with space film it
all i think would be such a cool
opportunity
i think it'd be great rvs are the way to
go yeah that's what i figured out vans
are nice
especially if they're decked out but an
rv you could go months and not miss
anything
that's what you said that's what i'm
thinking i think at some point i'd like
to do that
jack thinks he's going to be
third-wheeling we're not that bad
just bring it it'll be good it'll be
nice bring the puppy yeah we'll just
bring
bailey yeah so anyway i think that was
my only
complaint to you was it was it what was
it like watching my reaction to you
it was pretty funny i'm sure everyone
always says this but i had of course
seen all your videos
i loved your millennial money reaction
so i was used to you reacting to those
and kind of knowing that you know
you don't play it too uh careful and so
i was like oh gosh what am i getting
myself into
um but i was i was pleasantly surprised
that you could fully come for me and i
was
glad that you understood obviously
unsurprisingly the new york city
real estate market yeah which i knew
commenters would not right
i was like phew did you know he was
going to react to you no you must have i
actually didn't cross my mind i think
that was a new series you think i would
skip a new series
yelled to my boyfriend i was like oh my
gosh like i wasn't expecting this wow
were there any comments talking about
grammar oh yeah for sure and then when
you saw those yeah
i was like oh yeah it's probably gonna
come yeah yeah
did did any of my army come to your
channel
did this happen i think it must have
there was a little crossover because
then i
reacted yeah i saw that right yeah you
know we're just creating a youtube loop
here
right you know at some point and then
and then the next one that people have
been doing
what it was like to go on your next
coffee hour uh
chandler just did that chandler did that
taylor did that yeah you could do
that yeah what it was really like and
you get this is like the nicest stuff
ever but maybe you could clickbait it in
the beginning there you go
i love it i know it's like we're in semi
we're in pretty different spheres
in youtube so yeah totally oh you know
what that battery died
give me a sec i got another one yeah no
i'm always paranoid that uh something is
not going to record i've had it happen
uh three times i think where i've
panicked uh
one when i flew to florida and filmed
with ben mala
the entire trip was just like one day
with ben mello for like seven hours that
was it
his audio or no it was my audio
in the interview did not record anything
at all
and i figured it out when i left
it was done we missed the perfect moment
so if you see that video
the sit-down portion of him talking is
only him talking
and basically my portions just don't
exist because there's no audio to that
the other one when i flew to detroit to
meet with alex pardo millennial money
uh the entire first segment
of our audio did not get recorded i
think something was turned off or
something happened but i flew to detroit
to meet with this guy
nothing recorded figured it out at like
7 p.m that night we were supposed to fly
out the next day
and i called him up and i was so
embarrassing like hey man nothing
recorded can we do it again
and he went back to his shop opened up
we filmed the whole thing again
and then there was there was another
time i was just thinking about that just
nothing recorded bad man
oh yeah one of the angles was blurry the
entire time and then the other one got
deleted we deleted footage oh
yeah i've done that it's been there you
know what i've noticed it's
always on the trips where we travel yeah
it's the most important one yeah the
most important places
yeah on the biggest videos when we
travel is is usually when
it doesn't record but this time i think
we should be okay it should be okay yeah
perfect but you also yes please try it
let us know what you think
okay so this is my 20 cent iced coffee i
think i made yours a little bit stronger
than normal
no i like it do you actually i can make
it sweeter this is great i like it i
like
this not too much are you just saying
that no i tell you really okay you're
not lying i don't
know all right the only reason i say
that is because i made yours stronger
than usual i put more cream in it
i feel like it's safer to go stronger
than too sweet if you're offering
somebody coffee right
usually people like the really sweet one
usually i make it where it's but it's
also kind of weird when you hand someone
a coffee that's just like
drowning yes i hate that
it's a worse look yeah no this is great
yeah
it's more just like a like a liquidy
cream with like a little bit of coffee
okay all right so uh yeah
oh you also just dropped a bomb on us
before this and you said
that you're moving yes no
so you're moving out of the apartment
which your rent was like 1800 a month
right yes are you upgrading or
downgrading i am upgrading a little bit
because so i'm staying in new york so
not too much drama there not going too
far
um but yeah i mean the deal is the real
estate market right now especially in
new york obviously so many people have
left
are pretty good so i figured get a
little more bang for my buck
and since i have done better this year
and i'm obviously saving money on travel
and i used to pay for cargo space and
all this stuff like i'd rather invest if
you
under or not invest but you know i know
people you gotta use that word carefully
lifestyle inflation you know that's the
comments are gonna
attack you yeah value of life a bit more
if i'm gonna be inside
way more than a year's past so yeah new
apartment
why not just move somewhere else why not
do the whole
van life thing why not do that again
because that would reinvigorate i mean
that would really just
cause everything the algorithm loves
that you know i am considering it for
the summer
the hard part is my lease is up in
february where it's like what do you do
in february
so stay tuned for the summer content did
you do a little van life break
did you already sign something not yet
i'm looking actively i know i know
if i haven't found a place not yet if i
were you
yeah ditched the lease in new york come
back here i know
it's time for storage tempting put in
storage that's true live with your
parents live with your parents
i already did yeah just review it live
with your parents just for a few years
oh gosh invest everything no i'm kidding
it's perfect get an rv park it in their
driveway
yeah you live in there yeah take an
extension cord from inside
plug it in and all in all seriousness
my uns my unsolicited advice okay
ditch the lease then get get the van
uh start in california and just travel
for like three to four or five months
see how your channel is doing and then
reevaluate after about six months
i know it'd be so good for the channel
yeah would you guys inspired though
because i also think that's pretty
important would you be as inspired in a
van traveling across the united states
as you do in new york in the united
states oh yeah
yeah no a lot of like the travel content
i do would be more not like roughing it
but it's never like
i was not luxury travel i was like
hostile travel so i'm all for
backpacking and figuring it out i feel
like would be the equivalent
i would do that because i think for 10
grand you get a nice event you can
finance it right off the interest
and then travel to all of these places
that are just not crowded right now
i agree i'm interested there's not a lot
of people travel i think you would be
safe doing that
going to a lot of remote areas it's
probably safer for you to do that
in a van on your own then in new york
city
you could try new spots you could try
like the worst rated
restaurants in certain areas or the best
restaurants or whatever
uh shopping these are great ideas you do
shopping there
lifestyle content travel uh
just your experiences would you i i
think all of that would would do really
well i think you could double your
income this year if you just did that
would you do it i think i'm sold really
would you actually honestly stay tuned
this summer really i've been in the
not the summer now like it's cold it's
not cold
it's your life it's it's not it's not
that cold first of all the west coast is
not that bad now it's totally fine here
so you could by the time you get to the
i just slowly make my way back to the
east coast right well that's
what i'm thinking you go up and down
like uh like like this
yeah you know throughout the entire
country and i think you would do really
well
all right it's old i'm just gonna get a
car yeah i'll tell my boyfriend i'll be
like see you
would you would you travel alone or
would you travel with him
with a friend i've done quite a bit of
soul travel so i'm all for that as well
he has a more strict job so i don't know
what the [ __ ] is ability what does he do
uh he's a cartographer so he works in
like data mapping
sales i thought you said car photography
i'm just wondering what do we have left
to map because i feel like we've been
around for so long you're not wrong it's
not like
we're really like i don't know pulling
strings here like
it's more about pulling in uh like the
information of like where different
businesses are
in developing countries so if you go to
mexico you can't necessarily always pull
up your phone be like give me the
nearest 7-eleven
some of that information doesn't exist
yet and people are currently hanging out
so
that makes sense yeah i also want to
know like we always give
unsolicited advice to our guests yes can
we get some unsolicited or actually
solicited now
advice from you and just on anything on
anything
or are we messing up take your time as
well i can cut out any dead silence take
your time yeah think it through
ramsay does that when he wants the uh
the door opened yeah
outside no he doesn't he doesn't go
outside he likes he looks outside
and i remember someone told me or i read
somewhere that like
cats looking at a window is the
equivalent to a human watching tv
and it makes sense you said that so many
times to me now really
yeah yeah it's perfect it's profound it
makes it it changed my life that much
because now it's like when he stares at
their at for hours at nothing i'm like
it's like it's like me watching dr phil
or something
so all right my advice i'm just gonna go
with what comes
first go i would say dive more into the
lifestyle category
i feel like you've got finance covered
you've got you know real estate all of
that covered
maybe maybe try a little lifestyle do
you think that we have an angle on that
though
you never know if i think especially
when people when you have an audience
that gets to a point where they really
will watch pretty much anything they
that you put out or they really
like you as a personality that i enjoy
lifestyle content have you done any
vlogs have i missed
yeah the vlogs do the worst on my
channel like of everything i've ever
done i've done like two or three vlogs i
think ever and they all do like 10 out
of 10.
and then i'm like no i'm not gonna do
that and vlogs take me a long time to
film
because it's an entire day it's not like
i could just plan something out five
hours film it edit it
whole day of just filming then i gotta
make it exciting
and my day's not exciting i have to
really have to go out of my way to do
something that's
like noteworthy the finance community is
like they're fanatical
about finance they're like don't stray
pretty much
yeah okay yeah
well people criticize the way i used to
eat like a lot of frozen foods because
it was cheap so like the healthy choice
2.79
they said that was bad for me right so
maybe they're a little too a little too
quick
out of the lifestyle i have noticed
though just as a thought
that it took me there was almost like a
i don't know learning curve is the
closest equivalent i can think of but
like a learning curve almost a watch
curve essentially that
the beginning i'd put out a lot of vlogs
travel videos and for a while they
didn't perform well but i just stuck to
it and at a point
they became my most watched videos
because i think people just had to kind
of get used to seeing that on my channel
okay just put that out there so what
else besides that so do lifestyle stuff
living okay okay i think on this what do
you think about this to family
it's the family yeah is that your
audience uh no your family
would be joked about that becoming like
the next vlog that's the family
yeah it's like me bailey ramsay
uh macy do well
yeah we're not really like no no
children but we you know
the two animals and jack and jack
basically just like work 24 7.
yeah that's it yeah yeah i know sushi
vlogs this year are really hard to make
interesting people are like we want
vlogs inside i'm like do you remember
no there's not a lot happening like it's
one thing when you're running around new
york or traveling
yeah so bailey's done with her bone uh i
don't know if you want to just
hold i don't know if you want to hold
her you just got to be careful for the
wire but if if
she might calm down okay so it should be
okay
she might just calm down ah man
it's a problem with having animals you
know what i realized fish don't do this
this is why this is why i love fish
uh because they don't they don't do any
of this stuff bailey please stop it stop
stop
okay um so what other unsolicited advice
all right yeah i just want to show we
have
bailey right there and ramsay clawing
out the window
true true farm bailey it's like a zoo
she's gotta learn too not to jump on the
table
she sees ramsay doing it and she's like
hey rant if the cat could do it
so can i damn i don't know i feel like
you got your corner figured out
on the internet so everything else is
perfect
flawless okay i feel like i'm bringing a
little lifestyle to
your the lifestyle youtube category to
your channel well let's talk more about
your own personal finances can we can we
talk about that
okay your outfit looks expensive it's
it's not is it not does it look
expensive i don't i don't know i'm so
bad with this sort of stuff because
sometimes
you could get stuff at like not i'm not
saying you got it at goodwill but
sometimes
you could say like outfits like that you
could get a
no that's fair and no i'm not offended
because of them
i if you go back on my channel a lot of
my first videos were thrifting videos
perfectly there we go there we go okay
okay but how much was it how much was it
um so i thrifted the pants for about
fifteen dollars
not wrong yeah here we go it was
probably like 120 but it was
gifted so that's the perk of working as
a wow fashion content creators you get
some free wardrobe items
how much free stuff do you usually get
if i'm being honest that's the reason
why granted you know
so did you bring me some products um did
you i would have
known i have extra of what like that's
just
like a very fair question yeah it's
interesting how different are you
yeah yeah we were gifted hats and
hoodies
by chandler so like that's our level of
like free stuff yeah it's usually
load you up on skincare beauty products
some clothing got you covered um
but yeah i'd say the beauty fashion
world there is a
bit probably like a little too much
gifting it's not quite it's not very
sustainable
but my friends love me because when they
come over it's like a free store of
wow products to choose from okay and how
is how has your business been this last
year
yeah definitely it's been interesting
it's taken a lot of uh reevaluating
because like i
mentioned multiple times like i was
ready to travel this whole year
kind of go that travel focused route and
so have clearly had to pivot a bunch
so i've been focusing a bit more on like
new york city contents i've been milking
that a lot
so overall i did end up making more than
i did the year before and i think
because people were
obviously a bit bored they were a little
bit more engaged with social media so
i yeah definitely benefit off that a bit
that was one of the things that was huge
for me
back in i remember back in march
everything dropped by like
50 overnight i actually got kind of
worried because i'm like
i can't talk about the stock like how to
invest your money
because if if the market's going down
ten percent it's like i make a video the
market goes down temperature right
i look like stupid in the short term
right um and i was really
really stop it i was really worried
because everything dropped fifty percent
yeah um i i think there was like a
sponsor or two that were like we can't
we don't want to commit to
of course we don't want to commit to
anything now um
but then almost as quickly as things
went down
they just doubled i mean they everything
just went
nuts um and thankfully the the channel
ended up doing
really well last year same for you but
yeah like numbers wise too it just took
off
yeah i've seen it i would say ad rates
overall have stayed the same
but views went up yes i think more
people paid attention to personal
finance during a time like definitely
everyone was watching the market so like
i started working full time down
views went up and that balance came out
yeah i could pump up more content
definitely working in your hands how
many income streams would you say you
have right now
i would say okay let's see so if i
counted them separately you could say
instagram
sponsorships youtube sponsorships
youtube adsense
i sell photo presets which isn't a lot
like
so it is essentially like a lut you know
so i guess for someone who doesn't
know it's like a it's like a photo
filter that i've
created essentially and then you can go
into lightroom and you can use it
it's a popular thing amongst like photo
like is that what bryant
does yes okay exactly so it's people who
are like yeah are more into the
photography
realm or even like the artistic side of
videos so like a lut is what you'll use
you'll kind of like smack it on a video
it'll make it look pretty essentially so
photo presets um affiliate links
so like epidemic sound reward style is a
big fashion one
amazon things in that category and then
i'm finally working on merchandise i'm a
little late to the ball game on that but
that hasn't come out yet surprised
uh if you're in fashion you haven't done
a merge line or something like that i'm
very picky about it
i wanted to wait until it felt just
right okay
yeah her makeup makeup is a lot of money
there's so much money have you thought
about that well i don't really do a lot
of makeup makeup is like it's
its own kind of scary sphere it's very
intense in the beauty world but
there is definitely a lot of money too i
feel like people would rather
make it from a small creator with no
drama
just like agreed nothing to it just yeah
good makeup at a good price i'll have to
pitch this to my manager i'll be like
all right yeah let's go oh you have a
manager i do
how does that work why do you have a
manager do you not have a manager no
okay i guess that makes sense well i
also when i started i was like
when i started making money off of it i
was like 1920 yeah and i
was in school and um
it kind of just helped me be able to
negotiate contracts so i'm technically
i'm assigned to digital brand architects
which is like a digital
talent agency and technically i have a
manager
who manages probably similar contracts
helps negotiate brand deals
um will connect me with a lot of like um
on the ground
brands within new york city create merch
lines stuff like that so
are you comfortable sharing how much you
made last year you don't have to save it
you don't have to say how i could tell
you my average rates
your average rates for like innovations
yeah are you able to say that
i don't funny enough like if all the
things yeah that's the one i usually
don't say
that's the one thing i do because then
it gives away the competitive advantage
because one sponsor might be like oh
they're paying way less i could get away
with paying less okay
so that's the one thing i group them all
together and like last year i made x
amount from sponsorships but i never say
how much individually because when you
try to negotiate them
they'll use that against you it's a
bargaining tool it is i don't know so of
all the things we just saved you on that
yeah
yeah um free text or post text i would
say pre-tax
pre-tax yeah
do you know what is it i don't know i'm
like debating in my head right now
you can ball park it you can't so it
doesn't need to be exact
if you if you want if you want to i'll
make a large ball apart i'll say it's
between like it's probably less than
you'd expect
because of ad rates because i have like
half a million subscribers
so uh i'll say it was in between 130
000 to 200 000. or
that's exactly about where i thought it
would be yeah okay yeah a few
yeah no i was going to say 200. 200 250
is where i would say
okay but i also didn't realize the ad
rates were way lower than i would have
expected yes
exactly it's like i'll pump out a ton of
content and i'm not making any ad money
yeah
1800 makes sense if you're making that
money totally that's not bad at all
no honestly what you're spending is not
bad okay but what about what you're
investing are you investing in
yes good so i always max out my roth ira
i have since i was like 18. cool
um i have a 401k as well even though i'm
the player it's kind of just like
i have an accountant and they're like
just put your money in there for tax
purposes
some money in there so every accountant
says to do this i disagree with all the
accounts for the 401k
why um usually the employer sponsored
401k plans you have to do with adp
or it's like one of those like one of
those places they charge
such a high fee i just i looked into it
i didn't like any of their funds
and then i'm thinking well i think tax
rates are going to go up
and then i think i'm already in the
highest tax bracket taxes are only going
up
whatever i save now i'm probably going
to pay more in tax when i'm older and
making more money
anyway no i disagree i think because
your
tax savings that you have like investing
the money
will compound and i think that those
savings
will like sum to more than however much
you pay
no but you pay but you pay the tax later
anyway in the whole amount
and you don't get long-term capital
gains in a 401k it's all taxed as income
think about that first that's that's a
big one they don't tell you long-term
capital gains you could pull out right
now between zero and twenty percent
and then of course you have like the
millionaire sur tax and three something
percent
so let's say 23 but ordinary income
could very well be
at that time 45 percent maybe it's 50
percent
that's true that's what i think i could
argue with accounts i don't know
you're giving me an odd look i'm
assuming too that i'm gonna be in a
lower tax bracket when i retire really i
feel like i'm gonna peak while i'm
okay i don't know i feel like youtube
and this whole bubble isn't gonna last
forever really ride it out while i can
but at least you're aptly preparing true
because like i'm 24 now i don't see
myself
doing what i'm doing when i'm like 40.
what do you see yourself doing
to be continued no i'd love to go the
more
like documentary journalism realm like i
love video as a medium and i want to
explore that further okay
but for now i'm loving youtube okay yeah
cool
see i don't know i always feel like i'm
gonna make more money
in the future so i wanna i just wanna
minimize yeah that's
i should probably but i would say yeah
but i would say for you if
if you know for a fact you're going to
be in a lower tax bracket then
then it starts making sense but you
might be surprised
that this could very well just be the
very beginning i think the whole uh
like jack is telling you you could you
could go on this that the influencer
sponsor space is still really really
small and it's only going to get bigger
because think about it you made 2 000
for 800 000 views like 800 000 people
have seen this you got to think what
people are paying for like a super bowl
ad
and then dividing that by the number of
people you were able to reach in that
one video
and those aren't even endorsed by the
creator of the video holds the
credibility right
you know yeah i think i think sponsor
rates
for influencers is so cheap right now
you mean like brand deals
you mean like adsense both okay they've
both continued to go brand deals
high i feel like but two both continue
to go up though
ever since the beginning yeah and i feel
like they're going to continue like
brands are going to continue realizing
how much value influence was happening
and then it's just going to keep going
up as they spend more money it's going
to be like a positive
cycle yeah i think a lot of companies
are sleeping on youtube they just
don't know that like to to make a
youtube video to reach people
watch like youtube they don't get it and
so right now like the highest ad rates
are from those who usually
like like uh advertise e-commerce stuff
or social media marketing
and they're paying like 80 to 100 cpms
on some of this thing it's crazy uh but
they're they're doing that because they
realize like how valuable that audience
is and how easily you could tap into
somebody
uh even facebook rates are slowly
starting to go up as people
get in on that i think it's just the
beginning um same with sponsorships i
think
it's people are overlooking it or just
how powerful
uh just someone's word is like nelk i
talk about nelk all the time but
but they could say anything and their
audience they'd get a million people
just going on whatever website they they
say they'll never do a sponsor i
maybe they get endorsed by by some
gambling websites now but
um but beyond that um you've never seen
them really endorse anything other than
something they're involved in
and they get millions of people to go to
whatever they want to so i think it's
still cheap so i think you could make
more money i think yeah i think as
content creators if you're constantly
evolving yeah you can be in the game for
a while yeah
there's always a thought i'm like you
know youtube could just disappear
in a few years i mean in reality no but
i feel like having something that's a
little bit more uh
yeah i've been worried about that every
single year but oddly enough the
the longer i've gone on youtube and
you've gone on youtube longer than i
have
i feel like the more confident i am that
it's not going anywhere
yeah yeah it just gets stronger and
larger right
yeah so like in the first three years
i'm like it's the last year this is last
year but now like fourth year it's like
maybe it's not the last year maybe we
gotta i think the biggest thing is uh
just creator burnout
i would say that that's more likely to
happen than anything happened to youtube
and that's on you that's a really good
point
do you feel burnt out ever yes
definitely definitely i think because i
do a little bit more like
personal not necessarily personal
content but
a lot of it is like vlogs or things
about my life and who i
am which is a very strange thing to
share with like hundreds of thousands of
people
so i think once i pull back and i'm just
creating talking about subjects that i'm
excited about and less about
like my life i get less sprint out so i
think constantly uh
changing ideas finding ways to get
re-inspired and like
keeping content fresh yeah it helps
avoid crater burnout but yeah no
definitely i'll go through seasons yeah
the burnout is real what is something
that you are passionate about
outside of youtube and vlogging and
stuff like that oh
good question this is a boring answer
but i've like fallen back in live with
reading this year
so i'm trying to read like a book a week
in 2020 so that's a big
big one where i feel like a week book a
week in 2020 or 20 oh my god 20 21 what
what year are we
time is a concept um i wrote a
yeah so i'd say reading's a big one um i
enjoy
like the like a whole different side of
the the world of video kind of like i
mentioned earlier so like documentaries
and
things like that so i'd love to work on
kind of building skills to get to a
point where that's something that i can
maybe do
or at least be a part of projects
alongside that um
because i enjoy kind of that like
exploring like for example there's a
series on my channel it's called explore
new york city
and it's highlighting a kind of under
the radar neighborhood that you're not
going to find in your
tourist book so for example there's this
area called jackson heights in queens
it is the most diverse neighborhood in
the world it's home to over like 80
languages so
i love going to a place like that
finding a local tour guide through
subscribers
learning about the culture the history
of the cuisine um
kind of like traveling without actually
being able to travel so
things like that i love learning about
and kind of diving into
that answers your question that is
interesting i want to know a little bit
more about the books
yeah all right should we go back how
long does that take and
we're also almost halfway into like the
first week yeah so have you made
progress
i have i just finished a book yesterday
so you're ahead of schedule
how do you finish a book unless it's
like goosebumps
you could that would be fun read every
goosebumps yeah
yeah wow kindles i sound
so cliche but kindles and e-readers are
game changer because previously i'd
wait to go to a bookstore buy a book buy
one online when someone maybe recommends
it
but i have a goodreads account so i'll
create like a backlog essentially books
i'm really excited about reading
and then i can connect libby which is a
library
digital rental app essentially to my
kindle and read books for free
immediately so as soon as i finish a
book and i'm excited about a new one i
can
rent it for free or for just a few bucks
off amazon
um immediately whereas before i kind of
like wait to get a book and then with
the kindle i can bring it everywhere
like i have it in my purse right now
i read it when i had a little time to
kill what book did you read i just
finished
trick mirror which is a book it's a
collection of
essays it's like cultural she's like a
cultural critic
so like feminism and stuff like that she
kind of touches on and then i read a
fictional
just for fun book that was called the
seven or seven husbands of evelyn hugo
so those are the two i've read
in 2021 how do you continue to find
interesting books
like every week because even in picking
movies like i can't
do it like i genuinely i don't even
watch movies clicks
it's like 30 minutes just to find one
thing and then you turn it on and it
sucks and you have to find another one
i just i can't even deal with the stress
so i just turn it off and i don't end up
watching like anything because it's so
difficult to continue to find that's
because you could should be working
i know yeah and then i go back together
honestly subscribers come in clutch a
lot of times i'll ask in a like a post
like what was the best book you read
this year what's like a book that was
really
impactful or you just enjoyed and got
lost in and they they come through
do you do audio books as well i haven't
really gotten big into them i love
podcasts
but listening to like a seven hour book
i'm like i'd rather just read it what's
your favorite podcast
this one obviously yeah it was your
second favorite podcast then
okay if you don't know it it makes me
sound a little crazy but my favorite
murder
is my favorite i love true crime
so should we be one yeah exactly watch
out i know everyone's like what's wrong
with you
it is like top 10 podcasts on on spotify
or apple podcast i've never gotten into
that any crime shows like that i can't
wait
it scares me my grandma used to watch a
whole bunch of things this was when i
was like five or six years old like this
i don't know if it was true crime but
like where people were like just to
horrible stories and i'd listen to those
and think like that's going to happen to
me or this is like a break-in
so at five or six years old i would have
this thing where i'd have to go around
the house i think it was um
uh what do you call it uh when people
have compulsions
obsessive compulsions yeah ocd yeah and
i think it was like a
low variance of that because i would
have to go and check every door
twice before i went to bed because i was
afraid if i didn't lock the door someone
was going to come in and like
what i watched on tv was going to happen
and that lasted
years until i finally broke that but i
would have to go unlock
every door twice grandma scared you no
huh grandma scared you
yeah or grandma's show but even now i
just i get freaked out because that's
i don't like hearing about it it just
freaks me out because it's like
it's real like it's different than
watching like a zombie movie but like
i can't do that okay so now that i've
gotten my creepy one out of the way
another podcast i've been liking at the
moment is called she's on the money by
victoria
divine and it uh it started off as an
australian duo and it's basically a
millennial money expert who talks about
just finances
but i feel like there's not a lot of
like female focused material out there
and so that's what kind of do it to me
originally i was like okay here's two
women talking about money
and applying it to women's lives because
i feel like there's a bit of a you know
a disproportion of the general rules of
finance so really like that one just for
kind of touching on
why don't you make some personal finance
content like that you're cpm
you could do really you would make so
much money and i have some more coming
out i've started to like i'm all about
talking about
uh like the base level of financial
education so i mean i've sprinkled in a
few videos and they've done really well
and they've been
you know gotten pretty good views from
my channel been received well so there's
more coming out
noticeable higher cbms as well you
should do what you should do to break in
that is do a video what i spend in a
week
i've done one of those you have yeah but
it was like a year and a half ago you
gotta go deep i make a lot of videos
yeah make another like
if you do know we're gonna definitely
yeah we'll react to it make another one
go find my last one or tell me what you
think okay i'll do a quarantined version
towards it
they do well too they do really really
i did that and then i did uh like
mistakes to avoid in your 20s finance
videos and those both did really well
view eyes for my channel and i was like
okay something's going on here and so
i've since
made a few videos on like saving
budgeting uh very base level
you know what would do well how to make
a hundred dollars a day online in 2021
you would do so well i actually was just
brainstorming a video yesterday about
how to invest
100 and just like basic tips but making
money online can be a real oh no
i like both sides hustle world start off
with how to invest a hundred dollars in
2021
yes wait a few weeks and then how to
make a hundred dollars a day
a day online or something i'd be like
yeah i don't even know what i'd say
forever youtube channel just watch
graham's videos videos on something like
that
yeah i would start off do that yes i
would start i would do
do those all right stay tuned they're
coming out really well that's the plan i
have a list of finance videos that i'm
excited to make cool speaking of finance
how many credit cards do you have
i have two which ones
well i had like i got a beginner um
discover card just to be able to get a
credit card
i recommend that one just yeah no one
would give me a credit card because i
was young
um and then now i have the chase
sapphire great cards i think you need
the amex gold
okay that would be a good one for dining
sell me on it decent for travel
uh they give you i think it's like you
could find an offer fifty thousand
points when you spend
five thousand or three or five thousand
the first three months so you get enough
points back
good all-around card and uh i would say
good for right now when you're not doing
too much traveling but you're still
spending some money here there i think
it'd say that's a good card
amex gold mx gold i'm gonna look it up
yeah that's why i got the chase when
obviously it was for travel but that's
not really
yeah it's time for me to get another
credit card so get another credit i
think now is the time
um before you uh are you looking to buy
it like a house or anything at some
point
not at the uh i always like to look
because it's
i don't know i enjoy i think it's fun
not probably for another couple of years
at least a year or two but you know it's
in the
where would you be looking i think
realistically probably southern
california so my family's in orange
county and i think there's a few areas
left in orange county
that could be interesting to buy into um
but i love living in new york so
what about taxes yeah taxes in
california the mass the mass
exited yeah this is one of this is going
to be one of the uh one of the few
podcasts that we're going to film in
la because really most of this after
this after this is going to be in las
vegas yeah
well i guess for me the day-to-day
living
is worth paying a bit more taxes to live
near the ocean or live in a place like
new york city but i know that's not
everyone's cup of tea obviously
but have you been to vegas i have
exactly it's nice nice you know
okay you know why i love spending time
outside i love
like i either love the energy of the
city and the hustle and like the
constant opportunity of a place like new
york city or i love like the ocean of
california
and i know i know vegas you got you got
some outdoors
i actually did a trip with the vegas
tourism board so cool
got a little lay of the land back in the
day um
but yeah it's a really cool place but
where do you waste money yeah what kind
of stuff you spend on your money
okay how let's think about my money
break down here um
i say so this past year
the one place i probably could cut back
is eating out in new york i ate a lot
because it was like the one social thing
i was like i'm supporting small
businesses but i probably did it a
smidge
um i would say to give you guys a good
excuse i'm supporting a local man i'm
like
it's not lifestyle inflation i'm
starting local business and meanwhile
it's like masters
the cheesecake factory
yeah um because i know you guys love
numbers i would say i spent probably
around
per month around like 250 on groceries
and then
for eating out probably like 500 to 600
which isn't it's new york prices in new
york
you cannot find a meal unless you go to
chinatown which i love chinatown you
can't find
any meal under like 15 and there's tax
and tip and
you have to do a millennial money i know
that would be dude they would love to do
that
and that's scary it's pretty it's pretty
bold for people to put it out there but
it is i don't know
everyone's gonna everyone's gonna like
it they are so thorough though on their
finances i
hated going through the process because
it was worse than getting a mortgage
yeah they don't trust your numbers you
tell them and they actually caught a few
little errors on mine like i thought my
car payment was ten dollars
less than it actually was just ten
dollars like yeah it was something like
that like i sent them like 6 30 but it
was actually like 6 40 like some
little stuff like that but they
corrected every little thing i mean it
was
it was intimidating for me to have them
look through everything even the
apartment video which obviously not
nearly as much but they're like give us
the actual statements to like clarify
like this is the round price this is
like
gas electricity all that which i'm like
you know like gotta be thorough
yeah especially when glamour did their
video it was just how much you make
all right that's good no nothing
whatsoever but millennial money was like
they're all i think
they saw millennial money do it they're
just like well we'll trust them they
must be
they must be good that's true okay other
areas that i uh splurge
i splurge okay yeah definitely
food travel pre march
2020 um
maybe like health and wellness i like i
um have a this is really expensive but i
do f45
and for an unlimited pass so it's a um
workout class essentially where it's
like high like hit
high interval interval high intensity
interval training
and it's like 300 a month which i know
gyms are way
cheaper but for me i was like that's
gonna be my splurge this year okay
because you know
mental health benefits physical health
benefits you can't put a price point
yeah even like equinox is cheaper so
it's like yeah
there but i think for myself yeah it's
like things like health and wellness
i'll pretty much be down to splurge on
if i'm like is this going to make me
feel better
the the perks of the industry i'm
currently in is that i don't have to
spend pretty much anything on fashion or
beauty which i think for most
gals in my age range that would be
higher for them
um i don't know i'm trying to think of
something juicy i don't want to make
no it's not that's not bad it's it's
good that you aren't spending a ton of
money yeah
i think this year of course there's a
bit of that scarcity myself
let me reel this in and i've never been
a big spender yep i wasn't raised
that wasn't yeah so i think i've always
kind of had this mindset of like every
dollar counts
don't overdo it save for your future and
so
what have you guys talked about on your
other podcast like what realms do you
guys touch on
we've talked about biggest insecurities
that that's always a fun i don't know
what if you use insecurities if you want
to talk about that okay just
and and generally yeah okay
well you guys want to go first let's
hear something i've already done i've
already done it
you've already done it so many times all
right yeah we could go we could go first
if that makes you if that makes you feel
better i think i can
okay i can definitely come up with all
right go for it go for it
um well i'm interested you might not
feel this way but i definitely get
insecure about telling people what my
job is
for sure what oh yeah i hate telling
people silliest thing i've ever heard
you should be
proud of that and they're like what are
you i'm like i work in marketing don't
ask
why you don't fall away no i think i'm
still around maybe it's the new york
hustle i think
as opposed to like somewhere like los
angeles i think where people are very
accustomed to like social media
and most people in new york they don't
care but there are you know in general i
think
yeah being a youtuber carries a certain
connotation or people have a certain
perception of it or they don't really
understand what it actually entails
so i do get a bit insecure about being
like i never would i was
proud of that youtuber with like
self-importance honestly yeah i think so
or they're like
self-obsessed which i don't think the
average person who doesn't watch a lot
of youtube doesn't understand like
how multi-faceted like you have a
finance channel you have a tech channel
you have a travel channel like it's not
just this like
i post like selfies all the time i'm an
influencer i think there's a lot more to
it and there's a lot
of value that it can give etc but yeah
that's what i'm trying to get over
really
trying to be proud of being like i think
that's silly i think that's totally
silly you should be proud of it
i never tell people youtube by the way i
always say real estate just because i
don't want to explain
well i just don't want to explain i'm
not ashamed of it the explanation is
i just don't want to explain it and then
too if like a random person is asking me
i'm like well now i think you're
probably going to go look up my life
yeah yeah yeah
everything about me and like of course
i'm the one that put it out yeah but
it's like this weird
you know what they do the first thing
they do if i feel like i do youtube
oh really what's your channel yeah
exactly oh wow
two and a half million subscribers uh
yeah we just wish we should hang out
sometime
we should uh you will grab some lunch um
let me get your number real quick that's
what they always do and i'm like i don't
i don't give up
but it's awkward like can i get no no
you could send an email
oh an email oh what the
email you know jack
i check my email a lot yeah that that's
the part
so i like saying i'm in real estate but
then you usually get that oh
how's the market going it's like it's
good
oh yeah a place down my street that sold
for this was at a good price i'm like
i don't know maybe so it's just the
explanation i think it's becoming more
normalized it is
so as it gets more normalized yeah and
as i make content that i
really enjoy um all right well i never
would have guessed that
yeah all right i don't know maybe that's
okay i'm filming
yeah all right what else let's work on
this what else
okay now you guys have to share one um
well mine was my height
so that was what my height when i was
younger really because i'm so tall how
tall are you i'm six feet with no shoes
on so many shoes on i'm like six one
wow but you could reach like the top
cabinets that's something i could never
do
i gotta like stand on the countertops to
reach the very top ones
i can always yeah there's perks yeah
pros and cons
jack you're next um it's the stupidest
one you're gonna
uh i don't like how pale i am i'm really
pale
because you're under eye bags i guess i
guess it has to do with like mine
it's right out there it's just it's
under well it's been so overcast lately
i don't know i work inside like i can't
go outside and i spend
most of my day working i can't like go
out you got to ring the laptop outside
that's what i do because like this last
year i go
yeah i go i stay in my parents for a bit
when the pandemic was getting gnarly
and yeah i'd work outside just
i love working outside
yeah all right sorry we put jack in the
spot here gonna have a whole bunch of
comments jack's not pale he's not bad
yeah
it's so weird because we did the podcast
where we talked about our base
insecurities
and then we opened up you know and
people are like yeah well like
like graham was okay disclosing his you
know andre
who was our guest was okay disclosing
his i was a little bit like
more iffy on it but i just did it and
then everyone was like oh you don't have
to worry about that
jack jack's other one was he says he
doesn't have a symmetrical face which is
like
i thought he's like the most it's true
thing
look i mean you can see it's not
symmetrical i know but some more
asymmetrical do you really think do you
think jack's face is symmetrical no i
think it is it's okay if you say no
because i know
but but it's it's weird because now
people in the comments i still get
comments to this day that are like
jack you don't have to worry about that
your face is so symmetrical
and like that's kind of sweet but i know
it's really sweet and i really
appreciate those comments like don't get
me wrong i totally do but i just don't
want that to be like a talking point
true exactly because i'm constructively
into it yeah because like
some people commented on my instagram my
mom follows me
and they're like talking like you're
like oh i see what you mean now with the
asymmetrical this
and then someone someone responded to it
and they said how could you say that and
there's like this fight going on in one
of my pictures
i love this where two people are going
back and forth about my asymmetrical
horsemen oh my gosh
yeah it's just like so much attention
vulnerability you know
people dig in yeah someone's going to
come up to you in person eventually
and say like wow let me see your face
wow it's like really yeah
you have nothing to worry about man it's
you know i do get that like in public
because i'll say when somebody's like
uh-huh i'm taller they'll like see how
tall i am but then in public people like
oh my god you're a giant just because
yeah i'm taller than most people expect
yeah is your boyfriend taller than you
are you taller than your baby he's a bit
he's probably like an inch and a half
dollar okay he would say he's taller
than that
he's probably like six two okay all
right he says six three okay sorry
fletcher
yeah well can i use my height i said
that one earlier
yeah you guys have totally done one okay
uh mine i can't grow a beard
me neither oh i hate that i know i like
my body hair
wait um okay i can think of a good one i
don't like my nose
because when i smile it goes down all of
us do mine
mine goes flat like when i smile yeah
yeah yeah
yeah yeah why are you i like that what
i've never noticed that oh i hate i hate
it yeah people are going to notice it
because yeah
oh i see what you mean i'm like damn
yeah why did i draw it yeah like if i'm
standing normal
but if i smile it dips but
yeah i know no you're not yours doesn't
do that it's crazy
i one time i had this stranger because
like when i was i traveled solo i lived
in france solo for a bit
and i just had one time i was like
sitting in a tower of myself being all
a melodramatic 19 year old and this man
came up to me he's like i love how
expressive your nose is like
i was like and then after that i've now
always noticed that my nose
moves when i talk about how expressive
it is who says that
there's a weirdo was he hitting on you
or was it just like a one i was like i
want to sculpt you and i was like this
is getting weird i need to go
this is new york this is paris i want to
sculpt you
yeah i feel like this is something that
the locals say to like the tourists is
like a way to like
i know i know that's that's funny i'm
sorry yeah
it's a weird that's gonna be a numbers
game sort of pickup line yeah like he
just goes in and says like i love how
expressive and then
insert body part here let me sculpt my
nose
and then like out of a hundred times
it's gotta work once it's gonna work
enough for him to continue wanting to do
this
people are weird out there that should
be your go-to pick-up line what
i want to sculpt you i'm going to take
them back to my place right yeah
you just make a little like claymation
just imagine it's
really bad it's just horrible like you
know in third grade how you have like
the clay and
it's like pieces together looks like it
looks like a snowman a little bit yeah
i can see it now it's a numbers game you
just you say it enough eventually
someone's gonna be like
down to work yeah other times i'm gonna
love that have you guys ever lived
outside of uh
the states uh canada right
yeah my half my family is canadian so i
would go and spend about two months
a year okay there we're in canada uh by
toronto
london ontario okay to be specific but i
would spend about two months a year up
there
in the summer up until maybe i was like
18 or 19 and then it went down to like a
few weeks at a time and now i have not
been up there maybe two years
uh and now las vegas nice there we go
basically another
another world away have you yeah i
was born in france i lived there until i
was four but i'm not actually french my
parents were just working there they
didn't teach me french which i'm still
bitter about
um but i was 18. well i started
university i started azusa pacific which
is university
in east l.a and didn't like it and so
after a
year of it i was like screw it and i um
went online with my classes and like
dropped out of school went to a
community college online for
like a little over a semester and then
moved to france on my own it was an au
pair or a nanny at wow
yeah there's like a you can be an au
pair essentially and like live with a
family for free and then watch their
kids part of the day and then just do
your own thing
i didn't speak french i don't know
anybody i just kind of like sent it but
do you not speak french uh not really
just don't poo
just a little bit and that's when the
man said he wanted to sculpt my nose
yeah i have not been back since yeah i'm
like oh gosh magic vs how was the
sculpture was it good
i know i went the opposite direction not
today sir
it's funny because i've never told this
story now like hundreds about what what
about i feel like you should make the
story time right like i would have some
good study or
uh abroad story times like what else
yeah yeah um
this one let's see well one time when i
so i
like this one's not it's not that this
is like particularly funny but when i
so i backpacked alone in switzerland for
a while
this is another one i've never told
anybody because i didn't want to freak
anybody out but i was up and i was
staying in this really small
hostel and i like got sick and i
literally had a i fainted and had a
seizure
traveling solo and thankfully someone
found me but i never told anybody
because i was like oh no because i was a
little bit younger too i was like my
parents are gonna like
i mean i was paying my own way of course
my parents would never let me go
um i think i was like 19 or 20 at the
time
i was like 16. i thought like you're
like 14 15. like what okay
all right okay um but traveling solo is
always a fun time
how did that happen did they save you
out of the seizure
yes there was like immediately a nurse
checking in and was like
at the same hostel and she's like let me
help you or she like saw me fall and
then is that the first time you've had
it
yeah personally so i think it was like
high altitude because i was in the swiss
alps
blood pressure but that causes how long
were you seizing
not for long it wasn't that bad they
took you out of the caesar
seizures it was a seizure do you say
wake up
you're saying it like caesar salad the
caesar
uh it's like the have you guys ever
painted no it's like black
like starts to like it's purple yeah
it's like blackish purple dots start to
close in and then it goes all the way
i've never fainted
have you no wait don't do it why wow um
dude i got my wisdom teeth pulled out
and i woke up really late at night it
was like 1am and i had to
pee so i went to the bathroom and i peed
and then i went i was walking back to my
room
and i looked at myself in the mirror in
the bathroom and i just felt like
weightless
and i was like oh surprise you're
actually like
yeah i'm like what is happening i was
out of it and i just
like i started falling and i grabbed
onto the towel rack and i just like
pulled it down it made like a huge
rocket wow things started falling on the
ground it just collapsed on the ground
and then i just heard like someone
barreling down the hallway and my dad
opened up the bathroom
what is going on right now i'm like 18.
you know like i should be
was it ever scary traveling alone um
a bit there was a few times where when i
was in because i was 18 when i was in
paris i was a bit naive so there's a few
times where i probably should have been
safer than i was
um i went to berlin germany alone and it
wasn't scary
but i went to a few clubs alone or like
met somebody there like met a friend
through a friend and like would go out
to the clubs and then being out really
late alone is not always the best call
but overall i think it's uh especially
i've only done it at european countries
i haven't done other parts of the world
so in european countries
as long as you're pretty smart about it
and you overall are safe like i wouldn't
recommend going out
late alone and drinking or something i
like along those lines but if you're
playing it safe it's definitely doable
and i think it's like such
a good uh experience for most people
i've heard
it's more dangerous for some of the guys
getting mugged or like
lured away or like uh like
they put stuff in drinks and then you're
you're out and they take your
wallet and stuff no i i heard it's worse
for guys
yeah intuitively i feel like it would be
more dangerous for the girls
i don't i don't know i would feel safer
as a guy walking than i would as a girl
i just
i don't know that's intuitively yeah
that's not bad
i feel like they would go after a guy
because like they'll they'll have
money or a wallet or something just
but a woman would have a verse that
would be like exposed and your wallet
would be i guess so
yeah it's just risky across sports i
guess so
what is your least favorite place you
visited like was any place just
miserable
she'll say las vegas las vegas
final answer i feel like pretty much
everywhere i've gone
wait is the worst oh you like everywhere
yeah oh okay i didn't love vegas that
was the one
i love it's vegas it's not bad the nice
parts you know when you start
summerlin yeah yeah when you see those
areas it's nice i'm not a fan of the
strip
at all in las vegas i can't stand it and
i know there's so much more to it and
i'm just putting it in a small box yeah
i need to explore more i originally did
not want to move to vegas i i thought
like
as cool as it could be i just don't like
it yeah until i saw
summerlin and henderson saw the
communities and instantly have sold see
i feel like that's what i'm gonna try
out yeah
and what's your game plan like what to
you is bigger than making money at this
moment
or building like your youtube career oh
these are good questions
well i think when the world opens up
again i would love to travel full-time
for a year maybe get a van
mm-hmm a van in europe could be really
cool okay but that would be nice
yeah i i love it i travel so i'd love to
spend a year if you guys know the
channel cara and nate
check them out they're really cool yeah
there's the whole travel sector of
youtube that i'm a big fan of and they
just like went for a year
and their channel blew up because they
just dedicated and they just for a full
year they're like i'm gonna travel and
go for it that's something i'd love to
do
maybe get a van in europe um
and then yeah keep trying youtube out
and then potentially kind of shift into
other careers
taking the skill sets that i've taken
here and moving on forward kind of like
we talked about earlier might be in a
lower tax bracket
so hoping to save up a bunch now and
then have that flexibility in yourself
okay
is that preferable to you to change out
of the youtube career and to go on
somewhere else or
is that like a game plan that is like
secondary that would be like
yeah it's hard to say i think kind of
like i said yeah you i don't know
youtube is so nuanced and i think the
category
i'm in is interesting this like
lifestyle sphere so i think if i could
keep shifting and
creating content that i'm really excited
about i could see myself doing this for
a while
you could do a reaction channel those
are my favorites i love that you should
start reacting all right
yeah so like when they're talking about
like what they find attractive or what
they don't find attractive
all that stuff is so fast there's a
female version of that like someone
reacting to that from a woman's
perspective because i feel like it's all
guys
it's all guys it's like i watched um i
don't really watch pewdiepie but i watch
this video because it was his reaction
to like a 30 v1 or something yeah or
where a guy
picks out the most attractive right
they're so cringy but they are
they are interesting and you know the
women pick out who they think
is most attractive one through five of
themselves yeah but that's based of
i think they based their own personality
yeah they were kind of interesting and
they kind of had a skewed idea and i'm
like wondering like
i feel like it's kind of obvious who is
more attractive and who isn't out of
this group right
and then pewdiepie went in and he was
like okay clearly it's just this this
this this
yeah and he did he labeled them one
through five as most to least and i'm
like that is exactly what i was saying
i think guys are pretty much all on the
same age somewhat objective
to some guys i'm not gonna say there is
like one objective
you know okay idea of what beauty is but
like in some cases
you know do you think the women wanted
to actively choose a diverse
group of people to kind of be like hey
we're not i you know i think
potentially yeah sometimes when they
were
organizing it i felt like are they
trying to be polite that's what i like
are they trying to be like
because some of those some of those were
like i
i definitely don't deserve to be in
number one but they're so shitty
but yeah but you're so great you should
be number two
no no i should be number three it's
because they already have the confidence
they know they can take the hit
you know so they can give someone else
that's true as attractive
that's true or they don't want to appear
on cameras like guys
obviously i'm the number one come on
well also they don't want to be on
camera
like overconfident is unattractive
overconfident
yes so they they would rather be called
attractive than
think that they're attractive themselves
i feel like right depends what sector
they're in like
for example my roommate's a model and
like you know
she'll be because she's actively around
the most beautiful people
like as viewed societally in the world
like
i don't think she's as confident as she
deserves to be because i'm like you're
absolutely beautiful like you were
literally a model in vogue like
working for chanel whatever but because
she's surrounded by these people like i
think
you know there's like a song lyric where
it's like yeah models essentially are
like it's a billy either song they are
where it's like oh let's do it swimming
pool i don't know it's like something to
do with like models tears because models
could be bottled every swimming pool yes
how do you know this
that's like the one yeah the same right
where i'm like why did that discover
yeah so what is it
it's a profound lyric what is it uh if
teardrops could be bottled there'd be
swimming pools filled by models exactly
yeah so sometimes the most beautiful
people are still the most insecure
sure based off the environment they're
in so maybe around i don't know
i'll have to watch the video okay give
it a good little watch the video
react to it i think that would be
interesting to get your perspective and
you have to be completely
objective because it would be not very
it'd be kind of worthless to watch
someone say like
oh you know and then they obviously
they're not giving what they believe to
be true you've got to be hard you're
sure you've got to be people
there's different beauty ideas to
different people 100 yeah but
yeah i don't want to go into like there
is no you know what i mean it's just
like who creates the beauty ideals like
it's just passed out for media and then
who creates those
i don't know it's like cyclical yeah
exactly yeah it would be interesting
though to get your opinion on that
i'd love to watch it maybe i would start
doing that that's another thing
you could do that from a van
i'm not giving up i'm not because i know
for the van because i know
i know that you would be able to
increase your income by like
30 to 50 if you did the van and posted
twice a week
from the van twice a week twice a week
how long did it take you guys to edit i
guess you added
seven videos a week jack does four
videos i do three videos
the video i'm doing right now i'm
already five hours into it and i'm like
less than halfway through the article
one's taking forever oh yeah
it's gonna be a good job it's gonna be a
good video though how do you guys
do that i can barely pump out because
you get used to it one to two i know but
i'll work like like for me i'll take
like 15 to 20 hours at a video and then
i'm trying to do other things like i'm
doing instagram campaigns and
whatever that like i feel like i work at
full work maybe too much
b-roll maybe too much because like vlogs
and stuff like that take a really
cinematic
trick i've noticed sometimes with some
of the vlogs it's just like the quick
cuts no editing just
um
so those are the those are the videos
that um that tend to be the best like i
am a true believer
uh and shelby church is like this too
her videos
are so well crafted they're so cinematic
it's like you watching a movie
but sometimes it's just you want to
click a video zone out for 12 minutes
and just be done
and like you don't appreciate all the
b-roll all the work that goes in versus
like
when i've got it and then flip the
camera
flip it back like it's sometimes i feel
like that's good enough
it's good enough that's true i think it
really depends on the topic because yeah
if you're just like sitting down and
you're sharing information
you just chop it up real quick yeah edit
it and put it out but then sometimes you
want it to be
cinematic sometimes i'd probably go
overboard i feel like
if you took your editing down you cut it
in half but you posted twice the content
you would get 90 percent of the benefit
for half the work yeah no
i disagree i i really appreciate the
cinematic stuff like i genuinely do just
as a viewer i think it enhances the
experience a lot but
and also i think your time value as just
like an influencer is so much more
worthwhile than like you know your time
value as an editor
i encourage you to outsource your
editing just this past year i finally
started i put out like on my instagram
so i was like i need an editor so i'm
slowly starting to test it out
starting in your area like one that you
will be able to talk to
this is a jack jack so like i would edit
the phone calls which were super easy
just camera switching and stuff like
that but then i started editing all the
other stuff on the second channel of
course i watch this video so i'm
familiar with it that helps a lot
and then i i watched over his shoulder
as he edited a video
oh and that took that we did like two
hours of that maybe and then he handed
it over to me and i headed the second
half of the video i watched him at it
and i critiqued and he watched behind
the shoulder
the next probably two months yeah every
single video that i did
um graham and i would re-watch it
together and we would point out
like a lot of the things that we did so
we'd be like okay what about this cut
what about this as b-roll
oh what do you think about this graham
those are
but i was able to understand his thought
process as he's editing
and then of course i can't mirror it
exactly i can come pretty close but then
i can also enhance it with my own
kind of like idea and creativity and
stuff like that so i feel like it's a
good blend when they're able to
understand what
you know i know what you want in a video
and then i can also add on what i think
might be funny or creative
yeah yeah jack edits better than i do
for the second show because you put some
the time
yeah and some of the jokes what was it
you talked about leonardo dicaprio and
you put like adam sandler like i don't
know
yes there was something you did like
that it was so funny yeah
yeah uh i forget what it was but it's
just it's it's better because jack could
put in the time that i could not put in
that's that's fair yeah i feel like a
lot of what i put out so far i do kind
of rely on that cinematic value
and that is an element that i've like
consistently tried to include
but outsourcing i think is definitely
gonna be and you can make so much more
money if you're just like
filming and putting up more content i
know and then just outsourcing this
stuff because it's like the 80 20 rule
it's like you're spending so much time
editing totally when in reality like
that
is not worth a lot of money exactly well
then do you ever run out of video ideas
if you guys are playing
all the time all the time i i don't have
a video planned for friday
so like that's my pull it out of thin
air and just go for it well no i read it
and i spend like hours every day reading
the markets and i'm hoping there's like
some story that comes up that i can talk
about but if there's nothing
jack and i will usually talk about like
what good video can i make that's
different enough that i could just i
need to plan something because if i
don't do something in a day
i'm a day behind okay so then the seven
videos you're making
are you you guys aren't putting out some
videos
we've been doing that for over a year
yeah what
yeah this is a sunday okay i think i
need to follow your second channel
better
seven channels three days a week main
channel oh and then this part this
podcast sunday
yeah so we have monday wednesday friday
main channel uh tuesday thursday
saturday
second channel sunday this and you guys
plan on doing that forever
or the next day as long as we can yeah
yeah yeah
as long as we can i mean not a lot i
think like really year by year because i
can't think like 20 years out like doing
three videos seven videos a week um but
for the next like
year absolutely and we'll just we'll
play it by ear and we'll
adapt as needed yeah okay so i do want
to say
and emphasize this a lot though i am not
a huge fan of just like the lifestyle
content in general but i really
would watch every single second if you
went over a jubilee video yeah
every single second i would watch it and
i would be so content watching it i
would get a nice snack
i would sit in front of my team oh yeah
and make it like sit on it you could
make those like 20 minutes long
and people would watch all 20 minutes
that's the kind of video
like you'd see like pop up on your feed
and you get like that little like yeah
like oh yeah like let's like let me get
ready for this video get ready for it
and you get excited for it i would love
to watch that video
i feel like you got to like it's all
about the slow integration to your
audience because i think if i did like a
full 180 they
i'd get like i don't think so i get like
20 i don't i don't think
no i don't think so at all i think if
you just said like hey guys so
like we just went out yeah today and
like for 20 seconds
hey guys we just got back listen and
show it like a vlog style like turn your
computer around that's true look at this
this video from jubilee
30 versus one we gotta watch this like
this is crazy enough so let's let's go
in
and you can make it cinematic like you
could show the camera like over your
back
as you're watching it have a camera in
the front and just like talk
coffee so it's 20 cent iced coffee and
just critique the video
i think that would be really insightful
it's incorporating it into that vlog
style so it's like a little
i want to i have a feeling and you could
test this out next week
if you could that video get more views
than your other videos
okay within i would say within seven
days that
video title it um
i feel like that's the real challenge
how does um my like
i don't know if you do my response you
just work on whatever pewdiepie is doing
okay that's literally just put your face
in your thumbnail
over their thumb yeah yeah maybe a
little drop shadow or something like
that that's
good oh my god or summers will be like
who are you
or some sort of comment or remark that
introduced you want to use the title
like the 30 verses
yeah i don't know if my response to is
is going to be good to
get like that i don't know you could be
like vlog and reaction
no i wouldn't do vlog i would reacting
could be honestly good enough best of my
channel though really when i put vlog in
there
yeah reacting to reacting too yeah and
that wouldn't be a terrible
video to make like you just kind of
watch the video oh my god yeah wow
it's fun it's new filming right try it
but you have to be blatant
with like what you say yeah yeah like
pause it right before and you order
them around you got to be like one two
three four five
you could start with a guy one you could
start with the guy one first guy because
the guy one might be a little easier i
feel a little
worse judging women women likes
band together like
like trash any of these people like talk
bad about it talk about the men though
yeah
talk about the men all right here are my
thoughts i think that would be a great
episode i have a feeling it i i think
100k
it all depends on this just title and
thumbnails
all it is because the video i know
you're going to do well title and
thumbnail i love this
damn guy should just be my content like
strategy
yeah it's so easy because you see it
it's like already proven out
it's like it works empirical evidence
because jubilee puts a video
and he gets 10 million views plus and
you're like okay if there's an interest
of 10 million people and people know me
and i have an audience so they're
willing to watch it as well
it's like it's proven the proof is in
the pudding it is okay you know what
i'll take credit for this too
um shelby a while ago i told her to get
a tesla model three because of how much
content she could make from that she's
been pumping out those tesla videos
some of those are her most popular
videos because i was telling her like
you gotta get them all
the whole community is huge and if she
made tesla videos
would blow up and she did and i also
told her make a video about how much
money you've made on youtube
guess which i know i wrote a video the
other day her video
got more views than any other video that
i've done on that
and hers i think is one of the most
viewed videos if not the most viewed
video on
how much i got how much i make with like
a million subscribers or something like
that
it's like seven million eight million
views or some crazy amount you could do
that
yes you could i did consider that and
just show your revenue
and sponsorship now it's time for you to
do that like
everyone's doing that now at the end of
the year you could do
how much money yeah how much i made with
500
000 subscribers or how much i make with
500
000 subscribers uh that's the title yes
and
don't go into maybe you could go on
sponsorships and whatnot depends
if you want to lump it like lumps
by nda like i'm not able to disclose or
whatever totally
and then just i didn't actually watch
just a bunch of i just watched shelby's
there's a youtuber ali abdull yeah oh
yes
look at this oh my gosh yeah 50 minutes
i watch most of it i work
i usually what i'll do is i'll put a
youtube video on and then i'll work out
and it like motivates me to keep working
out because i'm distracted from the pain
and i watched that one i did skip
through a little bit but yeah like a
million
yeah like 1.2 million pounds or
something like this it won't happen
yeah so if you if you do this video yeah
and you make it cinematic in your style
yes
like you talk about how you got started
your bit of your story and then you show
the beginning and the middle and the end
and how much money you make and make it
like a 15 minute video i
i think easily a million videos but that
would get like really good rpm
yep so there we go we already got a few
topics for you
to take away with and that and and then
the van i really believe like if you
just
if you just follow this it's it's a
system
it's the syst this is what youtube wants
the algorithm is speaking
through me to you and telling you what
it is what it wants and this is
to live vicariously i know it's all
about your van life
interesting because i feel like i could
just come up with these great ideas for
other people and then
myself like i'm out of ideas hey maybe
backup plan you just become like a
travel consultant or you would like to
make a strategy firm
i wouldn't do i would love that you know
like i would love it where you have like
your income
we'll just call it 200. yeah and i'll be
like we'll split or we'll like i'll get
20
from everything you make above 250. so
like the first 50k i help you make more
that's yours but everything over 250
i'll get 20
of that it's like a few years but you
just gotta listen
i feel like that that would be
like income above a certain threshold if
you just listen
that's a good plan yeah if any creators
are out there watching this
you know email let graham know yeah
i wouldn't be opposed i think for the
right opportunity i would i would do it
but it's an investment as well i feel
like mostly that's what
ally's uh youtuber creator academy
i'm butchering the name he created a
course an expensive course
i think like not that exactly but
essentially having people
buy in and he like tells them how he
created his channel yeah i'm sure he
gives advice and holding
yeah but he's not taking a percentage
i'm talking like you know we're really
going to get down and dirty and we're
going to split it we'll take the time
yeah really going to do one-on-one but i
i get 20
that'd be interesting yeah i guess we're
pretty much
i think we're good i do want one thing
though yes because you're so
you are successful and you are young
okay
i think it would help if you gave us
some advice
and it doesn't even have to be about
personal finance or about youtube
you're obviously doing well in life what
what can you advise us
doing well in life yeah i think i'll go
off one thing that i'm trying to work on
is for one i feel like i've i've been
fortunate enough to
kind of find this career that i'm
actually pretty happy to get up in the
morning and work on which i can't say
is the same for a lot of people my age
so that has been a huge
benefit and i think you guys have
already kind of found that but one thing
i'm working on doing
is taking myself a little less seriously
and learning to chill more which i feel
like
you guys could probably do as well i
think
what do you mean what do you mean by
that yeah
get out um i know dare you
yeah i feel insult me in my own house
out of here i certainly and i feel like
when you work for yourself it's easy to
just work 24 7. so i've been trying to
be a little bit more active this year
at learning to actually you know go if
we've gone to a point where we're able
to
uh you know we've made good money we've
found a level
success take that time to enjoy it which
i am not good at i am like an achiever
at heart where i'm like i need to be
productive 24 7 or i feel like i'm like
messing up
so i am actively working on learning to
yeah i guess just be
more present and intentional and like be
appreciative of the moment
and that is really cheesy but that's
what came to mind
so i found it helps when you when you
talk about like not taking like like
enjoying it a little bit yeah sometimes
it really hurts my work
and i was i was that's the exact point
of it man
no but here's the thing just hear me out
okay uh i've always had this issue where
like if i take a few days off or i go
and like do something
it's so difficult for me to get back in
the focus of of working and find it like
oh it's like a grind and i just i'm more
likely to like slack off and not do
things and
just never it was it was alex becker
that got me into the whole
dopamine detox and at first i thought it
was like crazy but his thing was that
when you deprive yourself of like a fun
and like just all this like stimulus out
there like not the stimulus but
but like you know movies and like all
these things uh
your brain kind of resets to find the
more
boring things fun so that like if you
are not you like used to leaving your
house
you would find the most exciting thing
to do is like let's work and like plan
out videos and like edit and like all
that and it becomes so much fun
but as soon as you experience all this
other stuff that like really gives you
those big like hits of dopamine
it becomes harder to get back into it
because all of a sudden
your brain is like needing more than
sitting in front of a computer editing
is able to offer you
so sometimes when i just find myself in
front of the computer for like two weeks
straight
working i get so in the zone and just
produce like such amazing results
because there's like no outside
distractions at all like that's what
my brain now finds exciting it's like
the hedonic treadmill but like down it's
like
you're sloping down on the head no it's
not rather than up
yeah because you're depriving yourself
of all these new things
so it lowers your standard no not
exactly not it's it's
a hedonic treadmill is that you return
to your baseline your my
my baseline is now basically sitting in
front of a computer
that's that's what it is yes but in the
same but but i get the same level of
enjoyment
doing that yeah it's the overtime of it
that's what i'm saying it's like
it and you're depriving yourself rather
than introducing new things
to remain at the same level of happiness
you're taking away things
and you're staying but that just makes
it more exciting now to do my work
sure that's another way to look at it
yeah that is yeah
yeah so it's that's very interesting
okay well i guess i'm trying to learn to
okay what is it work to live versus live
to work type of thing have you guys
heard that
yeah i've never heard of that but it's
smart but it's like yeah
i don't know i mean i feel like if you
have a job that you love there's a
combination
you know there's a balance right there
especially when you hit that flow and
you're in the zone it's like such a good
feeling
but i think yeah learning to enjoy yeah
i don't know i i feel like it's
it's it's not good to work to live
because
then you have to do something just to
live i like the
time yeah you want to build something
that you're excited i like
part of your living to work because then
you have so much fun doing whatever you
do and like that that becomes
we're very lucky in that sense yes hit a
cool spot that we enjoy
but how much do you usually work a day
uh i usually try to stick to like a ten
to seven schedule but it always bleeds
over
so like i'll if i'm in new york i'll get
up i go to my workout class i sit down
on my desk i'm at my desk pretty much
the whole day unless i'm filming a video
or shooting with my assistant etc um and
i
try really hard to like cut off at the
end of the day but i usually end up
still
responding to comments and stuff like
that but i try to stick to that like
monday through friday mostly because
like my boyfriend my close friends
they're all kind of on that
schedule and if i don't otherwise i'll
just work every day
you know it's kind of hard to turn off
so that's the structure i try to stick
to
cool yeah so well thank you so much for
coming on really appreciate it thank you
for letting us confront you
we're almost to two hours this is one of
the longer podcasts that we've done so
thank you so much
and uh make sure to get your four free
stocks down below in the description
and check out my monkey pie m1 finance
if you want to follow that so with that
said you guys thank you so much for
watching i really appreciate it i'll
link to all your information down below
in the description make sure to
subscribe
uh pester her to respond to jubilee
and uh make some of that content get a
van travel
yep and uh that's it happy sunday well
no i don't want to say happy sunday
because you could be watching this on
another day happy
day of the week happy day of the week
thank you so much for watching all of
our information is down below in the
description
and uh yeah until next time until next
time cool
how are you what brokerage do you use or
what what are you going to be using
well right now i pretty much do
everything through vanguard vanguard's
great
i love vanguard it's easy to use
everything's there and
oh no what's wrong what do you have oh
lick no
i think she was she was biting her
finger and i think she
got to it yeah some dogs get so excited
like biting fingers
she can't contain herself it's like oh
like no no fingers
oh sometimes it's bad because if you're
like deep and focused yeah
like in something and she does something
you have like a great thought yeah and
she's not entirely potty trained either
so i took her out
hopefully she peed
the other thing is you could hold her
but i'm she'll just go crazy
all right let's just try all right guys
all right remember thirty thousand
eighty six dollars okay so thirty three
episode
of the oscars yeah iced coffee hour
thirty three thousand yeah okay i might
have to do two takes i'm not a smooth
youtuber right like
you're getting no we all do that we all
do that okay whatever
okay which any specific camera
yeah okay all right hello and welcome to
the 33 episode of the iced coffee hour
oh sorry you got to say ever yeah ever
33rd ever
episode of the iced coffee hour my name
is elena uh so far the podcast has made
thirty thousand eighty six dollars
twenty six dollars all right perfect
hello and welcome to the thirty three
episode
ever of the iced coffee hour i'm saying
no it's your third ever
do it again do it again do it again 33rd
ever 33 30
third ever ever okay okay hi um
okay just i'll throw these in at the end
if you're cool perfect
okay okay hi and welcome to the 33
guys oh no you could do it you could do
it we believe in you i'm getting a
little puppy laughing okay
hello and welcome to the 33 episode ever
i'm elena and
this is i ever got my thing wrong what'd
i do
31 i got it i got it
wait say it once hello and welcome to
the 33rd ever episode of the ice coffee
hour
my name is jack okay so far as of today
we made the podcast like just you don't
have to be do it like verbatim the only
thing is
ever is important okay and this is so
hard 33rd
yeah every episode um
also 33rd not 33. yeah why am i it's
okay if you say 33 that part is not
crucial
all right uh and then just introduce
yourself and say how much vodka's made
guys yeah feeling confident hello and
welcome to the 33rd ever episode of the
iced coffee hour i'm elena and today
or as of today the episode the podcast
as of today the podcast has made thirty
three thousand dollars and eighty
or thirty three eighty good
thirty thousand yeah i promise you
should we just keep it thirty three
thirty third ever ever thirty third ever
we make
thirty thousand thirty thousand
okay go